well fun as this is commander james has
someone special waiting for us in the
briefing room
let's get in there and find out what's
next
commander's waiting
[Music]
so where is it now
i helped
chase it away from a medical convoy
towards yavin it's pinned in the upper
atmosphere with no hyperdrive but too
many fighters for talis group to handle
alone
this might work out for both of us
come
meet a visitor
wedge antilles rogue squadron i hear
you're the reason i was able to finally
get a calm through
i have a star destroyer problem that
vanguard might be able to help me solve
we need a star destroyer for project
starhawk intact
now we prove what vanguard's made of
wedge if you would
[Music]
as you may have heard
talus group has called the imperial star
destroyer victorum above the planet yet
they're in tough
but it's presented a great opportunity
for us to jump in and not only disable
that star destroyer
but to seize control
so first we need to give ourselves some
cover by knocking out the turrets
naturally if we can also take out the
targeting system
that'll buy us even more time
next we need to prepare the star
destroyer for boarding
you'll need to find a potential breach
point in the victorium's hull
preferably near the bridge
once you find a good spot
bombard it
until the hull is breached
however we can expect that the victorium
still has plenty of tie fighters
they will try to stop us
once the skies are clear
we can bring in the boarding team
while our troops capture the bridge
vanguard will defend the exterior from
reinforcements
once the boarding team has seized the
bridge
and is in control of the star destroyer
we will rendezvous with the temperance
okay i think i accidentally made
stealing a star destroyer sounds simple
let's hope it is
the star destroyer
aren't you tossing him in the deep end a
little early lyndon
vanguard can handle it can't you
besides
project starhawk needs that star
destroyer for
well
you know
wedge made a name for himself at the
battle of yavin
he knows that system better than the
empire ever will
you'll be fighting on the rebellion's
old turf
so if wedge has any advice
you'd be smart to listen
you know a wounded krakana can still
bite
just watch yourself around that star
destroyer huh
get out there as soon as you can
[Music]
sorry for the speedy introduction
but talus group was counting on me to
get reinforcements fast
your commander says you have talent
enough to steal a star destroyer and get
away with it
normally i'd have rogue squadron for
this but general sindullah gave me a
temporary assignment to project starhawk
meanwhile rogue is handling
well
that's classified too
general sindullah keeps us busy
your commander and i have something in
common
i once flew for the empire too
at sky strike academy
turning to the rebellion was the
smartest move i ever made
i wish more of my friends had done the
look i appreciate the talk but uh talus
groups waiting for us
as you may have overheard
talos group has cornered the imperial
star destroyer victorium above the
planet yemen
they're in tough
but it's presented a great up so
naturally
next we need to prep
so we're headed to yavin
an exalted company it seems and now we
know project starhawk needs an imperial
star destroyer
that's enough firepower to tackle a
small fleet
or a means to catch the empire off guard
but that wouldn't warrant all this
secrecy
there must be more to the commander's
plan
we'll just have to trust him
too bad there isn't an easier way to get
what we need
even a damaged star destroyer has deck
upon deck of dura steel plating turrets
shields
my poor bigoted father called star
destroyers the fists of the empire
he wasn't wrong
but they can be beaten
if you're good
and lucky
let's stay optimistic
to yavin then let's not delay
the commander wants you on an x-wing for
this mission
got you outfitted with ion missiles they
disable enemy fighters and they'll
disable subsystems on enemy capital
ships too
good choice
tell me what you need
you got it
[Music]
this place always brings back memories
let's hope for some of that skywalker
luck today
all right ready vanguard
we're heading for the heart of the
action
vanguard follow his lead
this
for immediate is
captain antilles with that guard
squadron here to help
it's damn good to see you wedge we've
taken heavy losses we need that star
destroyer stopped
don't you worry we're here to hijack it
you're what
be ready
interceptors those have got to be the
first to go
agreed they're fast they work right
through our fighters vanguard prioritize
targets
that's it
[Music]
stay sharp
he's got a lock on me
[Music]
i could have handled it
then don't stop now
one more for me
that's it all ties down
good job vancouver
[Music]
and don't worry about the imperials
we'll keep them busy
steal that star destroyer
that's the plan
[Music]
okay vanguard on me
let's head for the victorium
focus your shields before they open fire
on us
shields
but stealing it
i like
right here and ready to go
[Music]
this is our chance to capture that star
destroyer
if we take the bridge we'll have access
to its internal systems
stand for a breach point so we can send
an aborting team
you're up five
breaching a star destroyer just like the
old days
look out vanguard we got a gunny story
incoming
vibe hasn't heard it
sure
just tell me when i can turn my columns
back on
if your comms are off how can we tell
you to no forget it
imperial fighters incoming
[Music]
oh there got my shields
let's keep looking
you can always count on me
[Music]
shields are down
will you
[Applause]
how about you preach that breach point
clear the skies
[Music]
these imperials just keep coming
my ship
fire
you're safe
get over to help frisk
that's it all fighters destroyed
[Applause]
thanks wedge fighter took a beating
though
great work
humans are on the way
we can bring the boarding team and
safely
follow me to the running
we'll give them
let's go
ready to take on a star destroyer
copy captain antilles just get us there
and we'll do the rest
you heard him
guide those wings into position
stay sharp
what about the star destroyers crew
if our boarding party takes the bridge
they'll slice internal security systems
the crew won't be a problem with no
computer access and all the blast doors
locked
[Music]
we've got an imperial carrier they're
launching reinforcements
they're not giving up their victoria
without a fight
they're gone take down that cruiser
[Music]
thanks
that was too
missiles against the close
nice ion missiles are great against
shields
you're hitting
lucky i was around huh
[Music]
to the
bridge carrier destroyed finally great
work
all right team
let's finish off the rest
branches
stay evasive
thanks
that was too close
[Music]
okay
regroup in my position
the boarding team might need support
we're almost through those doors
we've got another imperial carrier
that three carriers
that's a lot
get ready everyone
we're in
taking control now
[Music]
that star destroyer has taken down its
own carrier what a sight
yes the ship is ours
you actually did it
to safe harbor
wedge
[Music]
yes
you